Let's check in with, uh, where do we want
to go?
Let's try the two one seven area code.
Who's calling today from two one seven.
Hi David.
Hi.
Who's this?
Okay,
so my name is Aaron.
I have 26 year old truck driver.
Sorry if you're a my truck in the background,
I, uh, kind of have to, hopefully you don't
hear it too much.
No problem.
What are those?
Are those stick shifts or are they all automatic
these days?
Oh, this let's trust automatic and I hate
it anyway, so I'm not necessarily coming to
you today with a question so much as I would
just like to throw a different, maybe a different
opinion at you and maybe you can take it out
because in my own personal view, and I've
only been probably in politics for the last
year and a half, two years, I noticed something
that really does bother me about this country.
Everybody has their own ideas as to what they
think the problem is with this country.
But one of the things that I think probably
could be 10 because one of the biggest problems
with this country is that America has become
to complete with this current form of politics.
Explain what I mean I noticed that you and
Tom both made videos explaining how Trump's
legacy is going to outlast him and my first
thought is, okay, but why do they have to?
Now let me explain.
I personally believe that the president, being
the president of the United States is still
a job because at the end of the day it is
sure.
And if someone is not performing up to standard
at their job in any other places of employment,
they lose that job.
Right.
Whereas for some reason the president has
gotten away with it.
Now, what I'm saying is I personally believe
we're not, I personally don't think that having
a president at all is a really decent way
to run politics because if we acknowledge
the fact that America has a hole, it's pretty
much a huge social experiment.
I would say that the way we've done it, politics
pretty much since the beginning has not gone
as well as we would like because if you think
about it, how many presidents can you ne over
the course of this country's history that
have actually been anything good systemically
good for the American people,
so let me, let me interrupt right there because
here, here's the problem.
We have a country that is now 340 million
people.
We have the office of the presidency, which
is you could argue the highest office in the
land, but a lot of what happens in our country
is happening in the house and Senate.
A lot of it is happening in governorships.
A lot of it is happening in city councils,
et cetera.
So I actually think it's probably the wrong
standard to apply to presidency.
I mean, listen, I can answer your question
as you asked it and I could say here's what
Obama did that was good.
Here's what Clinton did.
But it's all arguably going to feel like,
okay, you're pushing the ball forward in one
area, but here's things that didn't go as
well.
Whatever the case may be.
That is actually the concern with Trump, which
is, aside from the tax plan or his decision
about Syria, he will have coarsened what counts
as political discourse ruined, uh, alliances
with other countries that have been built
over decades or longer, changed the, uh, appreciation
that we have for separation of powers by completely
flouting it.
Like these are the big picture things that
will outlast Trump that at a top down, uh,
perspective are going to be, they're going
to take a long time to fix.
And so when you say, name me any president
that's done stuff, that's good.
Well, okay.
That that's only one part of what the president
is does and represents.
The other thing the president does is sets
the sort of tone and political environment
in which all of the lower legislators operate
and that's where Trump has done so much damage.
So I just disagree with you about the framing
of the question.
Well that wasn't even my primary point.
That was just the, that was more to emphasize
the idea that that was more approved.
My argument that our current system of politics
isn't really all done
well.
There's no, I mean, listen, I agree with you
there.
I agree with you there and I hate to cut you
off, but I do have to run.
I agree with you there and there are so many
ways in which that's the case, whether it's
campaign, finance, separation of powers, the
judiciary, all these different ways.
I just think that it's the wrong framing to
enter it.
Listen, I apologize that I've got to run,
but we are short on time.
I do want to hear from you again Aaron, the
trucker.
We will put you in our system that way.
That does it for today.
Sorry for everybody.
I was [inaudible]
not able to get through, but alas, we always
have more people wanting to get on than the
number that we have time for.
We will take calls again,